NBA AND CBA AND HE SAID THE BEST
ADVICE FROM HIS DAD, HAVE A
SHORT MEMORY.
A LOT OF PLAYERS GET CAUGHT ON
WHAT JUST HAPPENED.
HE IS ALWAYS PLAYING FORWARD AS
THEY LIKE TO SAY.
CHRIS PAUL ONE-ON-ONE WITH
COUSINS.
SHOT CLOCK AT SEVEN.
PAUL A LITTLE SHAKE AND BAKE.
DRIVES PAST HIM AND LEFT-HANDED
LAYUP AND IT'S GOOD.
GORGEOUS MOVE FROM PAUL!
THEN COUSINS KNOCKS INTO PAUL.
ARE THEY CALLING A FOUL ON THAT?
WE GET UNDER A MINUTE REMAINING
IN THE THIRD AND LEAD BACK UP TO
12.
OFFICIALS TELLING THE PLAYERS TO
GET AWAY.
COUSINS JUST SHAKING HIS HEAD.
LET'S TAKE A CLOSER LOOK.
PAUL CERTAINLY LOOKED TO GET
SOME CONTACT.
COUSINS RAISED THAT RIGHT ELBOW.
PAUL SOLD IT EXTREMELY WELL.
>> Mark: WHAT MAKES IT TOUGH IS
CHRIS PAUL'S ABILITY TO SELL IT.
MARCUS COUSINS ALLOWED HIM TO
PUT A FOR SALE SIGN UP BY USING
THAT ELBOW.
YOU GOT TO BE SMART IN THESE
SITUATIONS.
>> Mike: THIS COULD BE A HUGE
CALL.
THAT IS JUST A GREAT MOVE FROM
PAUL.
TOUGH FOR COUSINS ON THAT.
>> Jeff: C'MON MAN!
>> Mike: DOES HE WANT THEM TO
THROW HIM OUT?
OFFICIALS RIGHT BACK AT THE
REVIEW TABLE.
>> Jeff: GOOD RESPONSE BY
PHOENIX.
>> Mike: THEY WENT UP BY 17.
THEN 10-0 RUN AND CUT IT TO
SEVEN.
NOW PHOENIX HAS ANSWERED BACK.
>> Jeff: MISTAKE OUT OF A
TIME-OUT IN THE ZONE.
CHRIS PAUL, WIDE OPEN THREE.
>> Mike: IF COUSINS DOESN'T
THROW THAT RIGHT ELBOW AND LETS
IT GO.
>> Jeff: MAYBE HE IS TRYING TO
GET IT OVER HIM AS HE IS TRYING
TO WALK INTO HIM AS WELL.
>> Mike: GOOD POINT.
>> Mark: IT DOESN'T LOOK LIKE
CONTACT BUT IF I'M EITHER COACH
RIGHT NOW, A LITTLE UNDER A
MINUTE TO GO IN THE THIRD
QUARTER OF GAME SIX OF THE NBA
CONFERENCE FINALS, LET'S CUT OUT
THIS.
>> Mike: TELL THE PLAYERS KNOCK
IT OFF AND HARD-FOUGHT GAME AND
PLAY ON.
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING?
>> Mark: WHAT I'M SAYING.
THIS WOULD BE A ONE OR TWO-POINT
BALL GAME.
YOU HAVE TO BE SMART AND NOT
SURRENDER TECHNICAL FOULS OR
FREE THROWS.
>> Mike: STEVE JAVIE, A BUSY
NIGHT FOR YOU.
A BIG CALL.
IT'S KIND OF WEIRD THE WAY IT
HAPPENED.
TELL ME HOW YOU SAW IT.
>> Steve: IT IS.
FIRST OF ALL, I SAW A GREAT
ACTING JOB BY CHRIS PAUL IN
FLOPPING.
SECONDLY, NOW THE OFFICIALS HAVE
TO DETERMINE WHETHER COUSINS
THROWS THE ELBOW OR NOT.
IF HE THROWS THE ELBOW, IF I
DEEMED IT THROWING THE ELBOW, I
WOULD CALL A TECHNICAL FOUL, NOT
A FLAGRANT FOUL.
IN THIS SITUATION WHAT THEY
MIGHT GO WITH A TECHNICAL FOUL.
CHRIS PAUL REALLY TRIES TO SELL
IT AND, OBVIOUSLY, HE DOES.
I UNDERSTAND WHEN YOU GUYS ARE
SAYING, TOO, ABOUT COUSINS JUST
TRYING TO TAKE THE BALL AND GET
THE BALL TO GO OUT OF BOUNDS.
SO THIS IS A TOUGH DECISION.
BUT THE MOST I WOULD SAY WOULD
BE A TECHNICAL FOUL, ONE SHOT.
>> Mike: THANK YOU, STEVE JAVIE.
>> Mark: IF YOU'RE -- IF I'M THE
REFEREE AND THINKING YOU GOT ME
BY OVERSELLING IT AND IT WILL BE
IN MY MIND REFEREEING YOU THE
REST OF THIS BALL GAME.
>> Jeff: I'D GIVE DOUBLE
TECHNICALS.
IF YOU WANT TO KNOCK IT OFF AND
YOU WANT TO --
>> Mike: LET'S HEAR FROM MARC
DAVIS.
>> Referee: UPON REVIEW,
DeMARCUS COUSINS WILL BE
ASSESSED A TECHNICAL FOUL FOR
HIS PHYSICAL TAUNT.
ONE FREE THROW.
>> Mike: STEVE JAVIE GAVE US THE
THOUGHT ON THAT.
ONE-SHOT TECHNICAL FOR CHRIS
PAUL.
COUSINS, MEANWHILE, THE PERSONAL
FOUL, HIS FIRST.
CHRIS PAUL TO THE FREE-THROW
LINE.
EXCUSE ME.
NO.
NO PERSONAL FOUL ON COUSINS.
JUST THE TECHNICAL FOUL.
ONLY THE SECOND MISSED FREE
THROW OF THIS SERIES FOR CHRIS
PAUL.
IN THE